wow thank you for being here i brought
you
presents look what i brought look what i
brought
oh look at that if you don't have enough
of conan
that's a great holiday you can have more
where do you get these were they
available those are
those are our design martha stewart
designs on kodak gallery wow look at
that that's beautiful
look look at this one yeah cause nothing
says the holidays like this guy
right here check out this one right here
that's great
you're an ornament really you really
should have your children in there
i think it says happy hanukkah conan
o'brien that's nice
good that's good these are great these
are fantastic can i keep these those are
for you
all right i'm gonna hand these out in
times square later no you have to order
you have to order them on on the
internet they you send your own photos
in and you get these beautiful cards
very nice so i just mail those in and i
get the cards back there's so much to
talk about i haven't seen you for a
while we have well first of all i i hope
you had a nice thanksgiving oh yeah
so much better than last year except for
the weather okay
but what was wrong with last year's
thanksgiving well last year was
on the thanksgiving from hell from hell
what happened
uh well first one little fork was
slightly out of line on the table oh
much worse than that cone and i don't
get upset about things like that anymore
anymore oh okay you're mellow now yeah
i'm very millet sure no
first uh first it snowed four feet
snowed four feet
i like it when it snows i like to roll
around i plan to have thanksgiving in
the barn in the stable with the horses
you know my horses that you've written
yes yes and um and so i'm your stable
boy
yeah gives me wishes and uh and then
and then uh so it snowed it was very
very cold so we set up a lot of kerosene
heaters those space heaters
and um set the table down there and then
my little dog francesca got kicked by
one of the horses because
they got nervous right so we had to take
her to the veterinarian but she was okay
okay then i'm carving the turkey and
i'm trying to multi-task and cutting and
smiling because we were taking pictures
from the magazine
i love that you're not just cutting the
turkey at thanksgiving it's also of
course
being photographed for the magazine
exactly it's on the world wide web
exactly so so i sliced my thumb almost
off
so i can't believe you made a mistake
well the knife slit
the knife made him oh the knife made a
mistake yes it was
it was the fault of the inanimate object
so i had to be rushed luckily one of my
guests was
um knows the hospital really well i had
never been to the hospital right
so i rushed to the it was rushed to
mount cisco hospital okay and
um westchester northern westchester
hospital and um
and they took very nice care of me but
my guests are eating the turkey
while i'm in the hospital so you've got
stitches at the hospital i had to have
stitches and all those things and then
uh because you know the celebrity goes
to the hospital they hit me up for
you know a million dollars well i had to
give a donation
of a million dollars because you're not
shooting my thumb
don't you have health care
the rest of us have health care in north
you're like what's done in this
situation
uh here's a million dollars
in northern westchester if they take
good care of you you have to pay back
well i'm staying the hell away from
northern westchester
let me tell you i'm known i'm a little
bit of a celebrity i go to the hospital
my head could be severed i'm not giving
them that kind of money that's not good
because you should support your local
hospital support my local hospitals and
there's my
payment that's correct actually you
don't have a gold truck back up now
you know they're building a new um
emergency wing and i wanted to
help them with that is your name going
to be on it no what
no not for a million i gave a hospital a
million dollars there would be an
electronic conan statue
no i i must mention this book because
this must i'm telling you something i'm
here for the book i know you're oh no
you're here
to see me and this book is incidental uh
if we get to the book we get to it if
not we just look at me
um this book i have to say is very
impressive this book has everything in
it this is the martha stewart's
homekeeping handbook it has i mean
i would there are some some facts i
would expect to be in here and then
there are some this book is so thorough
you have a a part in here that explains
how to organize your
firewood yeah i didn't think don't you
just dump firewood into a bucket or
something i mean
well where do you get it from from the
firewood pile
so yeah no it's it's all about it's all
about just this book is about
organization it's about keeping your
life orderly so that you can get on with
other things and have a nice life
right you know but um but uh you you
know what a quarter of wood is right
cord of wood i've heard the phrase court
of wood but i think like a lot of people
i don't know
what a quart of wood exactly is a quart
of wood is
a pile of wood a stack measure measuring
four
feet by four feet by two feet
what does it matter i mean why can't it
just be
oh it excuse me it's four by four you
made another mistake
i'm looking at conan and thinking that
you're not martha stewart who are you
rip
four by four by eight four by four by
eight yeah yeah sorry we were all like
she got that wrong i know and don't
worry i would get i'd get an email
tonight saying it was wrong
someone some firewood nerd would send
you an email
i once said i once said that um that the
plumb line talk came in pink and i oh
i got a lot of emails i can imagine
you live in a hellish world of your own
making
what else what else did you find
interesting uh there's a there's a part
in here that said that tells you how to
fix a squeaky bed
oh there's like a fly buzzing around you
what kind of show are we running here
i'm not kidding you're a fly they're
sorry yeah in my water
there's like a gnat flying around jeff
what is wrong with our studio it's like
a barn in here
jeff this is martha stewart from the
country yeah there's a gnat that you
were just talking in a napkin
right in front of your face i thought i
was trying to i was trying to ignore it
okay but uh no the how to fix a squeaky
bed you have squeaky beds you must
you
[Music]
i also better a couple of beds that are
squeaky and i have i
i they have to be repaired it's very it
is very shockingly embarrassing
yeah i can imagine yeah and you have to
sort of ignore it you try to ignore it
you know but it's
and then your house guests are hearing
it and
it's very very embarrassing so there are
solutions to that you know what i always
say
martha the plot if the bed is a squeak
and don't come a peeking
i'm such an ass uh i don't know why you
keep coming here
it makes me happy but everybody loves me
to come on come on
good oh good well they should you're the
best
seriously this book has everything you
ever need to know about anything and you
should get it it's the cyclopedia
it's great the martha stewart a
homekeeping handbook is available
everywhere
you